bonjour jean marc est ce qu'on peut dire
que bruno le maire a déjà une évaluation
précise de l'impact de cette deuxième
vague de l'épidémie précise non c'est
les services qui ont préparé la loi de
finances et le plan de relance qui sont
d'ailleurs en cours de début de
discussion à l'assemblée nationale
actuellement
eh bien ces services là non pas analyser
précisément la situation provoquée par
l'aggravation de la crise et surtout par
les nouvelles mesures de restriction
mais le ministre de l'économie il fait
de la politique comme tous les membres
du gouvernement et il a bien sûr entendu
la grogne la colère des gérantes baril a
senti l'inquiétude nouvelles de la
france entière et il anticipe un nouveau
coup de froid de l'activité vous savez
vous avez des secteurs entiers qui vont
avoir beaucoup de mal à redémarrer qui
aurait pu peut-être démarrer avant la
fin de l'année mais que rond beaucoup de
balles l'hôtellerie par exemple est
paralysé les transports aériens le
tourisme sont restés paralysés
l'événementiel le cinéma on a appris
hier par exemple que la sortie des
grands blockbusters de fin d'année vous
savez que traditionnellement la fin
d'année on sort des grands films pour
satisfaire les spectateurs de noël et
bien toutes ces sorties là seront
reportés à l'année prochaine vous
n'aurez pas de james bond
pas de walt disney je pourrais parler
des grands magasins qui vont être
évidemment affectées par le renforcement
des des gestes barrières et puis bien
sûr il ya tout le secteur des bars et
des restaurants dont on parle énormément
actuellement il est évident on va
retomber dans une sorte enfin du moins
gagnerez un risque de retomber dans une
sorte de déprime tôt on va freiner les
projets freiner la consommation avec un
risque de vivre au ralenti
il fallait évidemment réagir à tout ça
et où est-ce qu'on en est et ouest qu'on
est on en était de la situation avant
l'arrivée de cette deuxième vague
écoutez les économistes de bercy avait
préparé une note de présentation de la
loi de finances qui est qui était
relativement optimiste nous expliquer
que le plan de relance qui représente
100 milliards pour les deux prochaines
années
en investissement sera suffisant pour
que le pays retrouve son niveau de
croissance potentielle d'avant la crise
dès la fin 2021 c'est à dire que dans
plus dans un ordre 2021 noël prochaine
on aurait retrouvé le niveau à peu près
normal alors pour bercy leurs jeunes et
les efforts qui ont été faits été à la
hauteur à peu près au niveau de ce qui a
été près dans les grands pays européens
notamment l'allemagne sauf que le
problème pendant le week-end d'ailleurs
tout a changé puisque le gouvernement à
administrer de nouvelles restrictions
pour protéger le pays d'un retour du
virus et qui allait une fois de plus
aggravé la situation économique et
sociale donc poteau le maire m'a pas mis
24 heures pour changer son plan de vol
et tout va est trop tard parce que tout
va être retardée ralenti la croissance
ralentit et le chômage aggravé donc il
faut rebooster les moteurs il a donc
savoir un nouveau plan oui alors pour
cette fin d'année
les effets sont assez faibles parce que
l'état va seulement des quais c'est à
peu près 10 milliards d'euros de crédits
est juste à la fin de l'année c'est un
peu le cadeau de noël qui va permettre
d'amortir le choc
mais pour l'année prochaine 2021 bas on
va effectivement booster les moteurs
avec les investissements c'est à dire ce
plan de relance je le disais dans un
premier temps d'activité comme istres a
tiré par la demande du moins on l'espère
grâce aux aides sociales chômage partiel
maintenu et autres prestations et puis
dans un deuxième temps eh bien on pense
qu'à partir de la fin 2021
c'est l'offre qui devrait jouer à plein
devient les entreprises via les
investissements relocalisation
investissements verts etc
alors le scénario est assez cohérent
pour éviter ce retour au ralenti de
tourner au ralenti
eh ben on va accroître l'aide aux pme ça
c'est précis avec une baisse de l'impôt
sur les sociétés on va donner un coup de
main aux travailleurs indépendants qui
sont un peu coincé là aujourd'hui
puisque on leur oblige des nouvelles
fermetures en réduisant l'impôt sur le
revenu pour tous ceux qui investissent
dans une entreprise bon il va y avoir un
encouragement à l'investissement privé
dans les entreprises et on va renforcer
le fonds de solidarité sur pau au
bénéfice des hôteliers des
professionnels de l'événementiel des
photographes des fleuristes il ya un
certain nombre de professions qui ont
été ciblés comme ça et ces décisions
seront finalisés très prochainement le
début de semaine prochaine et annonce
hier soir est-ce que ça peut marcher
jean marc et goûtez ça peut marcher pour
calmer un peu
la colère certaines professions voit
bien mais le vrai problème si le défaut
de croissance et le déficit de confiance
de confiance
les gens n'ont pas confiance dans la
façon dont le gouvernement gère la crise
sanitaire donc ils se renferment
l'indicateur clé c'est le montant de
l'est par la consommation ne redémarre
pas dans ce pays les français accumule
une épargne colossale et on voit arriver
la fin de l'année qui est une période de
très forte consommation avec beaucoup
d'inquiétude beaucoup d'anxiété seller
parle de la peur qui reste stériliser
alors le miz économie est saine rassurer
tout le monde
il n'a aucun pouvoir bien sûr pour
éradiquer le convive
le problème c'est évidemment le virus
temps qui va circuler et bientôt on sera
obligé de porter le masque l'opinion
rappeur et quand l'opinion à perdre à
l'économie marche pas merci beaucoup
jean marc sylvestre